bonjour et merci beaucoup de votre
accueil de votre invitation c'est un
plaisir d'être avec vous pour partager
un sujet qui me passionne
comme on vous l'avait dit j'ai travaillé
15 ans dans le milieu communautaire dans
un organisme d'accueil d'intégration
plus personnes immigrantes et réfugiées
évidemment la question de l'immigration
m'intéresse beaucoup mais la question de
l'organisation communautaire et centrale
à ce que je crois et mon action
politique aussi donc j'aime
j'aimerais partager avec vous une
recherche que j'ai fait il y a
bientôt cinq ans sur l'opportunité de
créer un organisme fédéral qui
faciliterait aux organisations
communautaires et bénévoles de d'accéder
à des programmes de soutien beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus raisonnables beaucoup
plus reconnaissants de la contribution à
la société
alors pourquoi je m'y intéresse c'est
une initiative de réflexion qui avait
donc pour objectif d'observer les
pratiques gouvernementales dans le
financement mais aussi dans le soutien
qui est apporté aux organisations
communautaires et évidemment toutes les
répercussions cela peut avoir sur la
viabilité des organisations et sur
l'impact sur les communautés
environnantes s'avisait aussi et ça
reste mon rêve
la création d'un secrétariat permanent à
l'action communautaire autonome et ça
évidemment ça découle de mes valeurs
personnelles d expérience dans le milieu
bénévole et communautaire mais aussi
parce que je crois profondément que le
soutien bénévole et communautaire et que
la reconnaissance politique de son
apport à l'exercice d'une citoyenneté
inclusive aux principes d'une démocratie
responsable et à la contribution à la
vie économique m'apparaissent comme des
évidences incontournable dans une
société qui se veut scène et progressive
alors qu'est ce que c'est l'action
communautaire autonome je suis certaine
que dans toutes vos communautés dans
toutes vos villes où
cartier ou arrondissement vous avez des
organismes communautaires vous
connaissez des organismes communautaires
ça peut passer de la fondation de
l'école qui va soutenir les projets de
l'école locale à l'association de soccer
ou à l'accès au centre d'action bénévole
mais ça représente au niveau du canada
plus de 161 me l'organisation et ça
représente aussi 8 points 5 % de notre
pib
cc c'est considérable comme contribuer à
la à l'économie canadienne
les organismes communautaires répondent
souvent à des besoins il ya des intérêts
des citoyens qui ne satisfont ni le
gouvernement ni lire ni secteur privé
c'est un éventail très très vaste de
programmes qui est offert et souvent des
services essentiels
quand on pense juste au papa trop lente
par exemple qui fonctionne à base de
bénévoles et de dons que soient les
supermarchés ou ddd d'autres organismes
aide à contribuer avec la nourriture
imaginer la quantité de personnes qui
seraient en détresse vrai si on ne
pouvait pas compter sur sur une
institution qui est devenue la popote
roulante dans toutes nos communautés
donc il est difficile à gagner de ces
organismes en capital social ils
fournissent des solutions aux défis
économiques sociaux environnementaux
environnementaux et culturels et tisse
aussi et ça c'est bien important des
liens entre les citoyens
par exemple je reviens un peu ce que
j'ai dit le secteur bénévole et
communautaire est très très vaste vous
avez une multitude multitude
d'organismes qui vont des petits groupes
locaux ou très organisés aux très grands
organismes cadres nationaux comme
centraide united way j'imagine savez
c'est quoi le principe de centraide qui
recueille des fonds mais qui distribue
après sur des organismes locaux
ça comprend des organismes des
regroupements être les associations de
quartier les clubs de service
et centre d'hébergement des clubs
sportifs des maisons de transition
les orchestres symphoniques donc il ya
des fondations d'école il ya un volet
très très vaste d'organismes qui sont
identifiés sous le libellé de
l'organisme communautaire et d'action
bénévole d'actions b le communautaire et
bénévole
alors l'état l'association pourquoi est
ce que je me suis penché sur la
situation des organisations
communautaires et bénévoles est pourquoi
je crois que le gouvernement fédéral
devrait avoir une responsabilité accrue
pour améliorer la pérennité et la
durabilité s'organise à cette
organisation
donc nous sommes le cinquième pays au
monde avec un organe avec un système
communautaire autonome en en termes de
largeur et nous avons bon les pays-bas
les etats-unis le royaume-uni et la
suède qui nous dépasse mais en pro rata
de notre population
le réseau communautaire autonome et
bénévoles locaux au canada est quand
même le cinquième 73% de ses organismes
fournissent des services ou des produits
qui sont directs à la population
on revient par exemple à la popote
roulante c'est un service qui est direct
à un individu
le travail réalisé par le secteur
bénévole et communautaire équivaut au
travail à temps complet de deux millions
de personnes rémunérées on s'entend il
représente encore une points 5 % du pib
et c'est un ajout de 76 milliards de
dollars à l'économie canadienne
chaque année les bénévoles donnent au
delà de 2 milliards d'eur de leur temps
et s'empare des bénévoles ne parle même
pas du personnel rémunéré dans certains
de ces organismes je parle des bénévoles
qui donnent de leur temps de leur
énergie ou sectaire nous avons autour de
6 millions et demi de personnes qui font
du bénévolat dans toutes les
collectivités du canada et en moyenne
une personne qui s'engage dans un
organisme a tendance à s'engager dans
plusieurs donc en moyenne une personne
fait du bénévolat en fait dans quatre
organisations différentes sauces n'ont
pu le profit
actuellement le régime de financement
fédéral pour ces organisations et
privilégie le ce qu'on appelle le
financement par projet ce que je déplore
profondément plutôt que le financement
de base ou le financement de la mission
de l'organisation qui serait main enfin
mon option
donc il ya trois facteurs qui vont
distinguer cette ce type de financement
le financent une financement de base
étant un une aide financière ou une
subvention accordée par les
gouvernements provinciaux ou fédéraux
aux organes pour pour soutenir les coûts
d'organisation les coûts de loyer les
coûts de salaire les coûts d'assurance
tout ce que n'importe quel milieu de
travail a besoin d'eux a besoin
d'assurer pour que ça puisse réaliser sa
mission il puisse réaliser sa mission
par contre le financement par projet il
vise très particulièrement et uniquement
les coûts afférents à la réalisation
d'un projet donné par exemple le
gouvernement a décidé que l'année
prochaine c'est l'année où on va mettre
beaucoup d'énergie sur l'alphabétisation
par exemple donc on va approcher des
organismes qui sont de proches ou de
loin concerné par la fiabilisation et on
va leur demander de créer des projets
spécifiques pour cette année là pour
faire des activités en alphabétisation
mais les subventions vont juste toucher
à cela elles toucheront pas les autres
besoins de l'organisation tel son loyer
tous les frais fixes qu'une occasion
doit avoir les organismes bénévoles et
communautaires qui ont des ententes avec
de financement de base concert beaucoup
d'autonomie dans ce roman il réalise
leur mission donc c'est à eux de décider
où leurs conseils d'administration qui
décident quels sont les les priorités
que l'organisme va avoir pour les
prochaines trois quatre cinq années
c'est l'organisme qui décide aussi
comment répartir les différents fonds
est ce qu'on met plus d'emphase sur les
salaires est ce qu'on est plus d'emphase
sur les programmes mais c'est un
organisme de décider ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui viennent imposé tandis
que dans un modèle de deux ans modèle de
financement par projet c'est les
bailleurs de fonds qui contrôle les
pourcentages de chaque
qui est dépensé dans l'organisation et
c'est là la grande différence de ceux
deux types de financement et le
financement de base est en financement
de longue durée
c'est ce que je j'aimerais le plus pour
toute l'action communautaire autonome au
canada c'est de sentir que son action
n'est pas toujours sous la guillotine
si vous comprenez ce que je veux dire
mais quand vous devez à chaque année
faire vos demandes de subventions
re remplir tous les formulaires refaire
tous les rapports pour justifier votre
vie c'est extrêmement démotivante pour
le milieu communautaire
j'ai passé quinze ans j'ai un petit peu
de quoi je parle c'est c'est vraiment
décourageant d'avoir fait rage de
retrouver à chaque fois que ce qu'on
offre comme service est plus que
justifiable est plus que nécessaire par
la communauté donc un financement de
base ou en financement de missions est
en financement qui est à long terme 50
10 ans ça dépend d'eux
il y en a quelques-uns encore qui rsa
dépend du type de deux ministères avec
qui on fait affaire mais l'idée c'est
que l'organisme est assurée pendant une
certaine période de temps qu'il va être
financé qu'il n'aura pas à refaire des
demandes là de vous produire des
rapports à chaque année c'est normal on
parle de déni public non on va rendre
compte comment dépenser d'argent mais on
n'a pas besoin de refaire les demandes
de justice y est à chaque fois
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait ces demandes
là alors c'est une précarité qui perdure
depuis bien des années au début des
années 90 c'est vraiment quand les
gouvernements provinciaux et fédéral ont
changé la manière de financer les
organisations et ça ça crée une lourdeur
administrative qui qui qui a beaucoup
d'impact sur la prestation de services
directs évidemment si on passe notre
temps et à écrire des rapports ou à
faire des demandes de subventions on
accorde beaucoup moins de temps au
service qu'on doit rendre à notre
communauté c'est une d'aider les grandes
problématiques aussi le fait que on se
débat continuellement avec une avec des
manques de fonds on essaie de trouver
partout en typhon tiroirs ici un petit
fonds de tiroirs là une subvention
nouvelle à l'autre donc ces essais
auprès du gouvernement auprès des
fondations
on auprès des des institutions privées
du secteur privé c'est essayait toujours
de trouver des sources de financement
qui garantissent peut être une année de
plus de programme mais l'année de plus
de services à la communauté
et évidemment l'art de l'alourdissement
des mécanismes de contrôle des bailleurs
de fonds
c'est vraiment humiliant humiliant et
c'est le mot d'avoir à chaque année à
produire des dizaines de rapports pour
justifier 3000 $ vous recevez du fonds
d'action communautaire de la députée ou
de produire je sais pas combien de
rapports pour la subvention vous avez
reçu de ce conseil du trésor mais peu
importe la source
c'est humiliant pour chaque organisation
d'avoir chaque année ccl2 du mois de
janvier au mois de mars là on ne fait
que cela produirait avant et entre temps
la communauté que vous desservez atteint
que vous restez des services donc aussi
un autre fait et je n'hésite pas à trop
me lancer là dedans mais je pense qu'une
des grandes causes de l'augmentation de
l'action communautaire autonome dans nos
sociétés occidentales et le fait que
l'église où les églises ont cessé
d'avoir ce rôle qui était le leur dans
il ya 40 ou 50 ans donc il fallait que
quelqu'un prenne la charge de ce que
l'état ne prend pas en charge et c'est
l'action qui est très proche du citoyen
c'est l'action qui voit dans l'immédiat
quels sont les besoins qui est capable
de les remplir l'église le faisait avant
et maintenant ce sont les axes et les
organismes communautaires mais en plus
tous nos changements démographiques
signifie qu'il a une diversification de
besoin nous avons une société qui
vieillit donc que nous avons besoin de
personnes qui ont qui veulent garder
leur autonomie chez eux mais qui ont
besoin d'un certain appui certains
services nous avons nous avons une
société très multiethnique qui exige
aussi une diversion une diversification
de service assez considérables et donc
c'est nécessaire que les organismes
s'adapter s'ajuste à cette
diversification
il ya aussi un manque total de
remboursement de frais pour les
personnes qui font du bénévolat je sais
pas si vous en faites mais vous savez
très bien que c'est très rare qu'on est
un organisme soit capable de vous
rembourser vous vous frais de
kilométrage vos frais de stationnement
même ne va pas c'est très rare qu'ils
aient les moyens et l'autre grand défi
pour le milieu c'est le recrutement et
la rétention de personnel qualifié
on s'entend que si vous êtes à faire en
salaire de 40 90 dans l'action
communautaire et bénévole vous êtes très
chanceux généralement quand j'ai quitté
la maison internationale la rive sud
j'étais directrice générale en 2001 je
gagnais 30 7 milliards et j'avais au
delà dans millions de dollars de
subventions à gérer juste pour vous
donner une idée que c'est pas là que
vous allez faire votre argent ni votre
fortune
alors quel est le futur souhaité qu'elle
est mon futur souhaité pour l'heure pour
le milieu il y a un énorme consensus
partout au canada sur les problématiques
et sur les besoins
versez universités l'it et des
problématiques elle est reconnue donc on
s'entend que la reconnaissance du
secteur comme un élément essentiel de
nos sociétés d'avoir une politique
claire qui reconnaît le secteur c'est un
premier pas et ça de vue ça devrait
venir du gouvernement fédéral et yves
éventuellement si la création de cette
instance permanente que j'appellerais le
secrétaire est permanente pas l'action
communautaire qu'est ce qu'il aurait
comme objectif
il aurait le mandat de coordonner la
mise en oeuvre de la politique de
reconnaissance et de s'assurer entre
autres que l'impact sur les différentes
sur différents ministères concernés au
niveau du fédéral soit uniformisé
le spac devrait collaborer évidemment
avec tous les to les différents
ministères et organismes fédéraux et
même les autres ordres gouvernementaux
pour coordonner le le sens à donner à
ces subventions
il ya développé des mécanismes pour
assurer une
complémentarité de toutes les mesures du
soutien financier mais aussi des
objectifs qu'on se donne comme société
et le spac de le spac le secrétaire
permanent secrétariat permanent à
l'action communautaire devrait être le
point d'ancrage des groupes bénévoles et
communautaires et de leur vision de
servir de relais entre le gouvernement
fédéral et l'ensemble les instances
concernées
en plus le mandat d'assurer cette mise
en oeuvre de la politique de
reconnaissance et de soutien il
définirait les critères d'admissibilité
des différents organismes
o o ce pacte est à et soutiendrait leur
demande dans les différents ministères
les demandes la dette financière mais
aussi leur demande de reconnaissance un
organisme qui se créent dans une
communauté peut avoir besoin de soutien
pour pour faire valider sa mission ses
objectifs et ça serait une un autre des
rôles du secrétariat
alors c'est mon rêve c'est ce que
j'aimerais vous présenter comme comme
idée de ce que j'aimerais voir
éventuellement dans un gouvernement
fédéral et c'est ce que je m'engage
aussi à faire si jamais je retourne où
j'aimerais retourner
je vous remercie infiniment de votre
attention merci madame n 2